we have not won
and what I call the definition of
winning and three successive election
Cycles I mean here in California 2018
was a Wipeout we had a it was like we
lost half of Our obligation
2020. we lost the white house uh we lost
the house we barely clung to the Senate
2022 we're barely clinging to the house
such that there is a leadership race
that has conservative members of
Congress calling each other names on
Twitter that's and airing their dirty
laundry out in public and and we're
saying yeah let's sign up for another
two years of this and another election
cycle America can't afford for us to
continue to be the eight ball and
playing catch up with Democrats we just
can't and so if nothing changes
we are going to expect the same thing
and I I for one don't want to be sitting
here twiddling my thumbs well we're 10
20 years behind the Democrats
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the founder of Dylan Law Group an
absolute Free Speech Warrior I'm talking
First Team all free speech Warrior and
now candidate for the Republican
National committee chair harmeet Dylan
harmeet welcome back to the Reuben
report thanks for having me I'm glad to
have you harmeet and we haven't spoken
in a while at least on air uh and I
thought you would be the perfect guest
to be our last guest of 2022 because one
of the main messages that I'm always
pushing on this show is that good people
have to get involved and just in the
last couple weeks you have thrown your
hat in the ring and you're getting
involved so my first question I suppose
is are you nuts
yeah this question has been asked to me
by several people who love me and you
know
there there come if I'm sure Dave you've
had them where you were like hey let me
go start this new thing or let me leave
this cozy thing I have and follow my
dream I had that when I I've had that a
few times in my life and I I kind of
felt struck by that so I you know
discussed it with my husband we prayed
over it and you know we decided yes you
feel in your heart you have to stand up
and challenge what's going on at the RNC
because you cannot stand by and just nod
and have you know another shrimp
cocktail and pretend like everything is
going well when it's not and so that's
really I really felt compelled I've kind
of felt that way for the last couple of
years in fact but you know after the
2020 election debacle uh president Trump
endorsed Rana Tony McDaniel for a third
term and you know that itself was was
something that a lot of folks thought
well maybe it was time for new
leadership then not that it was her
fault but when you were in charge and
perhaps you don't you know quite pivot
and respond to changing election laws
and other issues and messaging
maybe it's time for a Fresh Approach
well you know we didn't have that and so
she did promise in her last run that she
was going to have a third and final term
and then suddenly surprisingly she said
she's going to run for a fourth term and
so I said wait a minute we have not won
and what I call the definition of
winning and three successive election
Cycles I mean here in California 2018
was a Wipeout we had a it was like we
lost half obligation 2020 we lost the
White House we lost the house we barely
clung to the Senate 2022 we're barely
clinging to the house such that there is
a leadership race that has met
conservative members of Congress calling
each other names on Twitter that's and
airing their dirty laundry out in public
and and we're saying yeah let's sign up
for another two years of this and
another election cycle America can't
afford for us to continue to be the
eight ball and playing catch up with
Democrats we just can't and so if
nothing changes
we are going to expect the same thing
and I I for one don't want to be sitting
here twiddling my thumbs well we're 10
20 years behind the Democrats and we
don't have to be because you know Dave
you know there's so much energy in our
movement there's so many smart young and
middle-aged people outside DC uh people
who who are social media Savage people
who are fluent with the culture people
who get that the base of our party has
shifted from neocon cold war warriors
and Chamber of Commerce messaging and
tax cuts for the rich to blue collar
workers and young people who are
energized about the future and want to
have a home and a family
um we are out of touch and I don't think
we need to be so I'm here to bring us
back into touch and have that attempt to
reform the RNC into fitting what the
base of the party is okay so I want to
unpack all that including some of the
Republican infighting and everything
else that you touched on there but
before we do all of that for for anyone
in my audience that hasn't seen you on
the show before or isn't that familiar
can we do a little harm meet 101 real
quick why did I describe you as a free
speech Warrior
well I've been doing
litigation literally since before I was
a lawyer
Lloyd Dartmouth at age 16. I grew up in
rural North Carolina and at Dartmouth I
became the editor-in-chief of the famous
Dartmouth Review newspaper that Dinesh
D'Souza Laura Ingram and many you know
now famous people on the right have been
part of and during that time uh three of
my colleagues were actually kicked out
of Dartmouth for something they wrote
about a professor and so back in the day
the American civil liberties Union used
to actually care about free speech and
they sent us a lawyer who who helped us
Sue Dartmouth so at the age of 19 I was
on 60 Minutes talking about Free Speech
issues on American campuses we won my
friends got reinstated set me off of my
pre-med course into a career in law and
so ever since I graduated from law
school now almost 30 years ago I've been
working on issues of Liberty and since I
started my own Law Firm we have focused
a lot on Free Speech issues in virtually
every context but we're well known for
our work
media censorship through Twitter a
couple of times three times where you
know just representing half of
conservative social media you know we
represent reporters who are sued by
politicians we represented the daily
wire in litigation in the United States
Supreme Court
um and you know project Veritas we've
stood up for their rights in court and
so it's it's a real honor because it's
really the epitome for me the first
amendment is first for a reason and it's
it's it's something so special compared
to the rest of the world even the
English-speaking World they don't have a
First Amendment we have that and so it's
a it's a passion to do that work and
probably a third of the lawyers at my 22
lawyer firm do that work and it's really
exciting
yeah and I want to give you a little
credit publicly that I've given you
privately which is that over the years
when I've had a lot of crazy hit pieces
written about me I've called you a
couple times particularly the one with
the New York Times when they basically
on the cover said I'm the head of the
alt-right and I was like you know can I
sue them and whatever and and you calmly
explained to me that unfortunately in
the world we live in even with our
liable and slander laws like it's tough
it's tough and it'll probably cost you
way more than it'll cost this giant
Corporation so you've you've talked me
off the ledge once or twice so I owe you
for that
yeah absolutely and and look now I don't
care for the record they keep doing it
and it's like now it's kind of funny to
me but years ago yeah you're bigger than
them and so what you know so that that
you know like believe me in fact the RNC
has been peddling hit pieces about me
and it's very upsetting but luckily I'm
surrounded by calm people who are like
the truth is there you'll Prevail and so
so it's all it's all good but
um you know
to leave a job that I'm very passionate
about two jobs I also started a
non-profit people who can't afford or
you know for other reasons they need pro
bono legal help for for free and that is
a very you know active non-profit Center
for American Liberty we represent
children who are targeted by transgender
groomers we represent
um people in free speech issues we
represent a host of other civil rights
issues
and to leave that in my Law Firm which
does the favorite part of law that most
lawyers would kill to be able to do all
day and get paid for it that's how
passionate I feel about this RNC thing
I mean I love my job right now I love my
jobs but I love America more than that
and I think that we're just driving this
thing off a cliff here and we can't
afford it so nobody else stepped up so I
stepped up I mean Lee zeldon talked
about it but ultimately didn't want to
take on the challenge because it is a
challenge and I stepped up so I'm I'm
gonna I'm gonna see it through
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless drivel check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell